the kids were with me and with their dad
and it was nice because they usually
have to travel a lot because of our
separation kelly clarkson sharing a rare
family update after her divorce from
brandon blackstock revealing she
actually spent her summer with her ex
and their kids of course
i am busy and i love all the time i can
get with my kids well kelly stepped away
from her busy schedule to enjoy some
family time telling the today show
tuesday how nice it was for river rose
and remington to have both parents
reunite post-divorce it's
obviously been a rough couple years so
it was really important to me to like
shut down for a minute what did you do
for that time some people have the time
to literally
four-wheeled in the mountains
the kids were with me and with their dad
and it was nice because they usually
have to travel a lot because of our
separation so we were both in montana so
it was really it felt kind of the first
time i think my kids felt a little more
centered as well so it was nice we're
sure kelly and brandon's kiddos would
agree brandon's been working and living
in montana full time as a rancher while
kelly has been getting candid about
navigating her new norm with their kids
in l.a
she's got her talk show out here and has
been a regular on the voice for years
but is taking a break from the show to
focus on family you took the summer off
of the voice when we were shooting this
next fall season when was the last time
you had a summer off uh 16 years old so
so i was literally and i don't think
it's maybe common for a lot of working
people you don't get summers off
generally like unless you're in high
school but like i just hadn't i hadn't
had a minute last june the singer filed
for divorce from brandon after nearly
seven years of marriage
divorce is a really
shitty thing
kelly and brandon went through a messy
split the two were in court fighting
over their parental rights and kelly
ended up winning primary custody in
november 2020 but the kids now split
time between households like i don't
know how anybody i'll just be real with
you goes through
grief like divorce any kind of grief any
kind of loss
without having an outlet like it has i
have written like 60 songs like
it's like an insane amount of getting it
[Music]
out the time kelly told et the divorce
process inspired her to get back in the
studio after she initially put music on
the back burner i have this record
that
we're working on that
is is really great and it's very honest
still the 40 year old mom admits she had
her reservations about being too honest
with her new songs i've never had this
difficult of a project it's one of those
things where i'm a human i'm going
through something huge and it's been
like two years and not easy with kids
especially that makes it just a whole
different dynamic i'm just navigating
like what i'm comfortable with releasing
it's coming i just gotta get my crap
together
yeah kelly's keeping her kids top of
mind and the music at bay but we're sure
a heartbreak anthem isn't too far away
[Music]
i care
100 more about my children than i do
anything else on this planet so um
that's been the the hard thing of like
yes i'm willing to share my experience
and yes it is
the worst i mean the past few months
have been
horribly sad but
at the same time i have to think
like what i say
is a domino effect into other people's
lives
[Music]
you